this is gonna be part two of a talk i
gave at the very beginning
of startup school on evaluating startup
ideas
and the thing to know about both of
these talks is we've
been talking about them from the point
of view of the investor
basically it was helpful
i thought to explain to founders how
investors evaluate startup ideas
and looking at that structure so that
they can better
understand their own ideas opportunities
and then
in this presentation present them better
to the people that they want to get
excited so a quick
recap in the first part i basically say
a startup idea is a hypothesis
for why your company is going to grow
really quickly that hypothesis must
compose of three different parts
the problem the solution and the insight
and the basic parts is
your problem should be pretty big pretty
pervasive
have a lot of these characteristics to
make it feel like there's a very big
market that a lot of people have the
problem
the only thing you need to know about
the solution is that you should not
start with a technology
you should start with a problem and
lastly
you're looking to have something that's
going to make your company
unique and have some kind of unfair
advantage
what that we call an insight that
will show why your company will grow
faster than other companies
i talked about five different types of
unfair advantages that your company can
have and kind of what are the benchmarks
for meeting them
now the thing to keep in mind
about understanding and creating this
startup idea
is that i don't need you to do all the
work
to lay all of that out in detail that's
stuff that you'll kind of want to know
or keep in mind but a really good
investor
will do that on their own they'll hear
what you're talking about
and extrapolate and so what
i'm going to cover in this presentation
is how do you package up that hypothesis
how do you take all the things that you
understand about your company and your
startup idea
and how i present it to an investor so
that they can make a
decision that's in your favor this is
the yc startup application
and basically this is the application
all the questions that we asked that yc
partners will use to evaluate your
startup
so down here when you're filling out the
yc application
we actually link to a couple of things
and one of them is how to apply
successfully i can't tell
because i read so many applications but
it feels like
founders are not reading that essay
uh it was written by paul graham in 2009
and almost everything in there still
holds to this day and people still make
mistakes from it so i'm just going to
like
point out some stuff and really like
punch it in here
while i have your attention so here's a
quote from that essay
basically we believe for every company
that we will interview
at yc we bet there's probably another
company
that's just as good as them out there
but
they messed up on the application and we
didn't realize it we didn't invite them
and basically the reason is
because they didn't express their idea
clearly
that's it like you might think oh i
didn't show off all that complex stuff
about my startup idea
and that's why they didn't pick me and i
want you to know
that's not true and so the first thing i
want you to keep in mind
is i do not need you to sell me
as a yc partner right a good investor so
average investor what they do is they
talk to you when you tell them about
your idea and it feels like they're
poking holes all the questions asked
about what's all the reasons why this
could go wrong
a good investor does it the other way
around they hear what you say
and they imagine and they use their
optimism
and they use knowing that some kind of
rare event has to happen for you to
become a billion dollar company and they
try to imagine all those rare events
that could possibly happen to you
and then they pitch that path back to
you
and so we are really good at selling
ourselves
so you don't need to do that and the
thing is
you guys are kind of bad at selling
things in the beginning right
and what i need you to understand is
that i'm trying to evaluate
these three statements when i'm hearing
your idea
do i understand it am i excited by it do
i like the team and do i want to work
with them
surprise in your weekly updates
when you do your group sessions these
are the questions that we ask you to ask
one another
it's basically the questions that we're
trying to figure out for ourselves
and we're hoping that every week when
you talk with other companies you are
practicing
getting feedback and understanding
whether you're able to instill this
in other people so your goal is just to
be clear
i will do everything else so
back to the application these are the
only two things we're going to focus on
today
what do i put in the what's my company
going to make how do i describe my
company
in a very efficient manner the first way
to do this
is to be clear the reason we focus on
this is because a clear
idea is a foundation for growth and what
i mean by that
is that the best companies in yc or
around the world
grow organically they grow by word of
mouth
what does word of mouth look like it
looks like this it's basically
i talk about your company what you're
doing making etc
and i'm the most interesting person at
the dinner table and i tell it to other
people
and those people want to tell other
people that's it
word of mouth is something where i
remember what you do
i talk about it enthusiastic and it
spreads on its own
marketing and advertising it's a tax i
believe companies pay because they did
not make
something remarkable now before anyone
can remember at the dinner table
what you do they have to understand and
so i have
very simple rules for how to make things
easy to understand
this will sound familiar if you're
familiar with an essay i wrote on how to
design
a better pitch deck and i'm going to
focus
on basically saying that the way i talk
about designing a pitch deck
actually works for ideas and lots of
other things and so the way i make
things easy to understand on a pitch
deck or a slide
is to make it legible i make it simple
and i make it obvious
in today's presentation we're just going
to focus on making
your idea legible which is going to
sound interesting
right for clarity now in my essay
i talked about how at demo day
when our startups are presenting to a
room full of a thousand investors
it's kind of an interesting audience
number one the audience is filled with
really old people
they tend to not have very good eyesight
as a result
they all can't sit in the front row like
you lovely people
some of them have to sit in the way back
and stand up
and that means if you create a legible
slide they have to be ones that even
old people in the back row with bad
eyesight can read
now how does that apply to a legible
idea
well basically you are designing a slide
that democratizes
the idea right and so people who are
blind or people who are ignorant
you're basically designing something for
everyone in the room
not just the ones in the first row so a
legible idea
can be understood by people who know
nothing about
your business that will make things very
clear to the widest possible audience
now this is super important because you
will
talk about your company more than
anything else
it is actually the thing that we are
really great at
at y combinator we have our companies
constantly
practice talking about their startup
startup school
curriculum is designed around helping
you constantly
practice talking about your startup and
this is because
you are going to need a lot of people if
you're going to
become a billion dollar company so you
are trying to find a co-founder you have
to have a way of talking about your
company clearly
whether you're getting users or
investors or employees or shareholders
you have to get really good at this and
you have to be able to do it
quickly and efficiently here are things
to avoid
that makes things not clear that makes
your idea muddy
the first is ambiguity right
so that's like obviously the opposite of
clear
or straightforward something's a little
abstract something can be interpreted in
two ways and therefore
it might take a question to understand
what you do
complexity so i have a very specific
definition of complexity
and so if you look at the root word
simple and complex
come from the same root and having to do
with twists or braids
things that are simple are ones that
have one braid
and things that are complex have
multiple braids they're intertwined with
one another a simple idea is one idea
that does not fold a complex idea are
ideas that are intertwined
so simplicity means you are not trying
to mix a bunch of things
in your description mystery
um so this is an odd one but what i mean
is
anything where it's like i'm not gonna
understand
what is going on when you're talking
about your company jargon is one
obviously any words that i don't
understand anything that's fake like
indefinite pronouns
so if you just use this etc and you
don't describe what those nouns are
and then things that you just suggest
but aren't explicit about
and the last is ignorable and so what i
mean by that is there is some language
that we will just ignore so
in ux design people will create a sort
of blindness
to things that they don't want to look
at or they don't find to be of important
value
so for example ad blindness is a big one
that people sort of understand and the
thing is when you're talking about ideas
there's a way of using language that is
also easily ignorable
things that just won't stick in your
head things like marketing speak
there's probably lots of stuff that you
heard about that mba speak
we're kind of like puff yourself up
talk that doesn't give any extra
information
and then buzzwords and so when you say
certain types of words that as an
investor i've heard over and over again
or i will equate with zero
information or value then i will ignore
them and the result is
parts of your pitch will end up being
not even heard by me
and therefore i will not remember them
what you want to do
is be conversational a great pitch is
one where you can tell it to your mom
and she gets it
she's proud of you right
she's not going to shake her head and
that means it's got to be conversational
and that's really good for word of mouth
because we
talk in normal conversational speak we
don't talk
like an mba we don't talk like ceos all
the time
so it's best to talk conversationally
again avoid jargon words that are only
you
understood or used by your industry no
preamble
we'll have some examples of this but
if you want to be clear let's go
straight to what you want to talk about
let's not have a winding path to
eventually getting there
and the last one this one's a big one
it's being reproducible
so when i hear your idea can i imagine
it in my mind
can i see
what i would have to build to create
your company
if i don't have that then i have no
picture in my head about what your
company does
and until i have that picture i can't
ask any of the questions that helps me
understand if i'm
excited about you or understand other
nuances of your business
to make things reproducible i need to
know nouns
i need to have objects that i'm going to
imagine in my head and there's three
types of nouns that i should understand
from your startup idea first one is what
are you making
i should be really clear what is the
problem
and then who is the customer the two are
kind of related to the market
right but i should have these kind of
three nouns
in my head so let's go through some
examples
this is says we are going to transform
the relationship
between individuals and information
that sucks the thing is we see this all
the time
number one all the nouns that you have
see see down here
are abstract they're ideas i can't
reproduce based off of this
as zero informational value i still have
to ask questions
to answer the three nouns that i need to
have this is a bad description for a
company
we will see stuff that starts like this
when we ask describe what your company
is going to make
i don't even want to read it but
basically it starts talking about the
story
of the company or basically it's like in
the beginning
there was this problem and we're gonna
go through this issue
right and then there's these bad guys
and they showed up but then who's gonna
save
us we're finally here to save and you're
like i have to read another thousand
applications
that's not gonna work for me
this is the description on the actual
application that airbnb
put to yc airbnb is the first online
marketplace
that lets travelers book rooms with
locals instead of hotels
it's concise it's descriptive i
understand
what they're building i have a sense for
what they're making and then i can start
thinking about my other two ideas of
whether i'm excited about it
and then am i going to like this team
here's dropbox synchronizes files across
your
or your team's computers
the thing about this is it's refreshing
but also
there's no pretense they don't
they aren't playing defense i see a lot
of company descriptions
where they're like i'm worried about
this or i've gotten this kind of
feedback and so they give up clarity
to make themselves look bigger and blow
themselves up
or make themselves try to look more
interesting they're trying to
protect themselves against something
away ahead of time and the whole problem
is usually what it ends up doing
is it brings me farther away from you
all that padding that you've put on
yourself
here's a description from a company in
the current batch lumini is building
x-ray vision
for soldiers and first responders
we don't have to go deep into the
details i don't need to understand
how they exactly do this etc
this creates a foundation for my
curiosity
now i will start from here to try to
figure out oh how
do you do this is this the right team to
do this
how far along are they do they have
traction do they have customers i start
going down the route of asking all the
right questions based off this one
description this is a good one
here's another one so vahan in the
current patch is building linkedin
for the next billion internet users
so doesn't
perfectly connect me to what they're
sort of making
but i'm intrigued i'm excited about
someone building into linkedin
and i know it's some kind of social
network for business people and so now
i'm curious about how
i don't need you to answer how in the
description but i understand what you're
doing
and then now i can start making
questions in my head about like how
would i evaluate whether this is
working or successful or promising or
not are this is the right team
do they have a certain amount of
traction etc it gets me on the right
track
now the reason i've used this example is
because we have a lot of companies who
try to use the
x for y and what i mean by that is like
linkedin for whatever or uber for blank
or airbnb
for blank and so that x for y is super
useful
because it allows you to shortcut
business model
and some kind of complex behavior right
and then attach it to some other
vertical or something that you're trying
to
make work x or y
is okay but most people abuse it or do
it incorrectly so i'm gonna give you
some tips
first should you use x for y uh sorry
for your legibility
number one is x a household name this
should be like a billion dollar company
right you can't use uh your
uncle's like pet shoe store as the x for
this
because people don't know your uncle's
pet shoe store and they don't know if
it's successful or not
right so everyone as many people should
know about this as possible
and for an investor it should be clear
that it's a billion dollar company
opportunity everyone has to agree
that it is successful so you could have
a really big x everyone knows about it
but it's infamous
right so the people don't think it's
successful so be careful of that
does y want x so is it
really clear why the
target that you're going after wants
this kind of
model applied to it this kind of
solution
applied to it whether it's airbnb 4 or
airbnb
or uber 4 etc it should be really clear
that that's a segment that's either
missing it
it's not being served well by the other
one and also that those people
want to have that kind of model
and then the third one is y should be a
huge market
so if you're building
uh x for y and the last part
doesn't sound like a really big business
that's not going to work well for you
right because what we want because
you're essentially saying that
you are something but that's a subset
and what we want to make sure is that
subset feels like it could be really
really big
if you choose a subset that sounds like
it's going to be really really small
investors won't be as interested it
doesn't me it means that i'm worried
that you will not have
enough potential headroom to grow to
become a billion dollar company
so here's an example that doesn't work
so we had a company in the batch that
started off by describing themselves as
buffer for snapchat buffer is a nice
company
but definitely smaller than snapchat
so don't want to do that all right
so basic summary for this section
lead with what not why or how
you don't need all that other stuff that
stuff gets in the way of your clarity
for the most part
i'll read like a thousand applications
every single batch
and it's a really hard thing to do
basically even though it's my job
it's really really difficult to have
that much focused attention
across all these different applications
so i need some empathy i need you to
help me out
and what we want is that when i bring up
your application and i'm looking at it
let's make our intimate time
really pleasurable right let's make the
time that i spend on an idea
very efficient i'll look at it i'll
understand really clearly
i'll move around your application and be
like oh i'm kind of excited maybe
there's going to have this and i'll look
at that part i'm like oh they do have it
that sounds awesome
oh what about this oh that sounds
awesome too
what we don't want is media to go like i
don't know what
what are they talking about then i have
to like go to your website i'm like
don't know what they're talking about i
don't know how this sort of works i go
back to it i try to figure something
else out
i try to see if like some other partner
might understand what you're doing
etc super inefficient
is there going to be room for me to get
excited as a result
so to be efficient we need to be concise
concise
the best way i want to keep this in mind
is to use some examples
and so here's some things i need you to
keep in mind
yes i want you to be concise use as few
words as possible
and what i want you to understand is the
concision
is actually gives me secondary
information
about you as a team it lets me
one know that you have thought deeply
about your idea
because you thought so deeply about it
and because you've practiced talking
about it so much
and you've gotten really good at getting
people excited and understanding
everything really quickly
you probably have figured out how to do
it in a short amount of time
so it lets me know that this is a
founder that has thought deeply about
the idea
the other thing about being concise it
shows me that you are efficient
and if you are efficient with your words
then you're probably efficient with your
thoughts
that means you're probably also
efficient with your actions
and what that means is that i will start
to believe that you understand what is
most important about your business
you understand how to communicate it
clearly and you might actually
know how to always figure out the most
important part of what to do about your
company to make it grow
to make it work etc so
there's a minimum stuff that we want to
have even though we're trying to be as
concise as possible
again i want to understand the nouns so
if we're so concise
that i can't understand these then
your concision is too much the other is
i
want to get to this point when i read
the concision
or this short version of whatever it is
you're talking about because again i
know there's like a hundred thousand
reasons why your company is great
but when i'm reading your application
i'm only going to maybe remember
two to three of them and so we have to
try to make sure
those most important ones come up to the
top
this is a real startup school company
description
it's an online e-commerce store
i can picture what it is but again it's
not a description that helps me get
excited about it
it doesn't help me lead to all the other
things i have to do now more work
to understand why this is fast growing
and his potential
i also don't know based on this some
nouns i don't know exactly who the
customer is
is it people that they're selling stuff
to or are they making an e-commerce
store for other shop owners
just ambiguity security services
this is most of the descriptions that we
see on startup school
it makes it really hard for us to
understand it
a meritocratic decision support system
the thing is i want to know for what
for whom i don't even understand what
the problem is that they're solving
based off of this
and so is it for
is it because a lot of people have
non-merit basically i have to ask so
many questions in my head to figure out
why
did they get to this sort of description
learn and sharing knowledge about data
science and artificial intelligence
sounds more like a mission i can't tell
what the product is
and how they're so we're going to go
about it like i couldn't reproduce this
if i had 10
companies build based off this
description you'd have
10 very different products the other
thing that's odd about company
descriptions is you guys tend to
capitalize and make proper nouns very
weird
words and phrases you should not do that
it's not like a magazine title
um and it makes me think sometimes
you're emphasizing the wrong things like
you're thinking the data science and
artificial intelligence is the thing
that's going to make me excited
and the thing is like those are the
buzzwords those are the solutions
and it makes me worried that you haven't
started with a problem
let's give an example of like how to
adjust
a description so here's a much longer
one so our company will make
low-cost and low-power consumption
medical devices based on artificial
intelligence
and iot suitable for sub-saharan
communities
now relatively clear i can understand it
reading it
but it's not the most concise form of
this and i feel like there's a lot of
things get in the way
and so when i work with companies to
help shrink and reduce
and improve their descriptions so that i
will get the most out of it
um i want to talk through the process
the first thing i want to do is just
figure out what are the nouns in the
description
here we go our company medical devices
for sub-saharan communities oh [ __ ]
we're almost done
right everything else that gets added on
here
whatever verb adjectives or average you
want you want to be really careful
you want to know like is it giving
maximum punch for this
right and so really
the verb is going to be usually just
you're making something
etc um but usually it's going to be
whatever the product like the verb is
like
the thing that we're making if we're
thinking about this in an
active voice structure the subject the
verb
and then the object the customer the
market the people we're going after
everything else if we add anything back
to this i really want to be really
careful about
why we're going to add back to it is
that going to be the stuff that makes
me excited so the artificial
intelligence and iot suitable stuff
that's like how they're one gathering
the technology and i'm more worried that
they're wanting to use buzzwords to
describe it
right hopefully that's like a secret
weapon that you have but i bet it's not
the defining characteristics
of whether this company is successful or
not and then up here i see two
modifiers for medical devices low cost
low power consumption
so low cost i can definitely see that's
super interesting if you make a low-cost
device
in sub-saharan community then i'm like
oh that's interest that's really
interesting because that's like it's
hard just to make something
you know for developing countries but to
make it so it's
actually affordable for them that'd be
interesting the low power consumption
i can give or take there i'd have to
know more about the company to know
whether that's actually crucial
to understanding whether this company
has an unfair advantage
or not so if i was to redo this
we come out to we create affordable
medical devices for sub-saharan africa
some people are going to be very
screamish about this a lot of founders
are worried it's like you're putting me
in a box man
it's too reductive my business is
complex
i do a lot of things and a lot of things
make me great i want to tell you all of
them
and the thing is like you don't have
time and i know it
as an investor there's no investor that
thinks any business
is like simple and easy i just don't
think that from the default so you
shouldn't
be worried that i'm going to think
something small of it
and again you want to be careful of the
defense on here
once i get to this then i'll start
asking the other questions
it creates that foundation for curiosity
all right we're pretty much here at the
end the best way to help
me and i would love for you to help me
is to be clear and concise
thank you very much
you